I have an absolutely great set of
panelists for today all of whom by the
way are Stanford
alumni so happy to say that this is this
is a good group sitting closest to me is
Miss Jang Jin who uh got her MBA at
Stanford and she also holds a master's
degree in social psychology from Soul
National
University uh Jang HEI grew up in South
Korea but she decided to embrace a new
life in Silicon Valley when she got her
NBA she's worked for over 10 years in
international business development in
the video game industry and in 2015 she
joined a company named vingle which she
will be talking to us about uh more
today she is currently the general
eneral manager for the US for uh vingle
sitting next to Jang he is Dr David
Bruner and David is an entrepreneur on a
mission to create intelligence software
that makes uh professionals
smarter so sitting next to Jung he is Dr
David Bruner who uh is the founder and
CEO of module q and uh he'll be talking
to us more about module Q before
founding module Q David got his PhD from
Harvard in information technology and
management a program that combines it
and also uh business studies and uh he's
also worked with the Chief Information
officer of shen Bank to um study their
uh it systems and he uh was involved in
the the design of the bank's next
generation of workflow systems uh he is
fluent in Japanese
and as we'll find out a in a little bit
um some of the investors in module Q are
from Japan um David is the person I've
known the longest
here because back in the year 200000
David organized the very first
asia-pacific student entrepreneurship
Summit at Stanford which has been going
on yearly ever since
2000 and uh brings in about 40 to 45
students from top universities all over
Asia for a week here in Silicon Valley
so you were a real Pioneer at Stanford
too and um sitting next to David is Buck
G and buck is an executive advisor to
ascend a nonprofit Professional
Organization that is enabling its
members business partners and the
community to leverage the leadership and
business potential of pan
Asians uh he co-founded the advanced
leadership program for Asian-American
Executives which is an Executive
Education Program in the Stanford
Graduate School business he actually
retired in 2018 from Cisco Systems where
he was vice president and general
manager of the data center business unit
um he got into Cisco because his uh
startup company was acquired and uh he
had uh been the president and CEO of and
systems which was acquired by Cisco uh
he's also worked for these companies you
might have heard of like hulet Packard
National semiconductor 3com uh and he uh
has taught uh computer and electrical
engineering courses at Stanford and
Harvard and he got both his Bachelor and
master Howard not Harvard Howard Howard
I can't read uh anyway and he he did get
his Bachelor and Masters in dou from
Stanford and he got his MBA from Harvard
okay now we're set so in one of the very
first sessions when I talked about
what's going on in Asia I mentioned that
in an innovation system you have three
main elements to look at you have to
look at people flow Capital flow and
idea flow and as it turns out I think
our three panelists can address exactly
those areas so uh first of all I'm going
to ask Jang he to give a few prepared
remarks on uh what's going on with
vingle and how vingle shows idea flow
from Asia to the valley go
ahead thank you hi everyone my name is
jongi Jin and as in slide actually I go
by JJ at work uh so I just decided
to you can't hear me can't hear you
cannot uhuh no put it up a little closer
to your throat is it better no is it on
is it better it it should be on they
control that back there all right I'm
going to try to speak up a little bit
yeah
better yeah so I go by JJ after
realizing my name my name chongi is not
very easy to remember or hard to pron or
it's a little hard to pronounce for most
of my American friends so if you want to
contact me after this class just feel
free to call me JJ or jongi I like both
names so uh the professor introduced me
briefly I uh came to the the US in 2008
to do my MBA Stanford and actually
before that I've spent my entire life in
Korea until 2008 and I worked in like a
several different companies mostly
working in business development and
business strategy
for international expansion of those
companies I worked for and I think I
should that's why I could be invited to
this you know great session to talk a
little bit about my
experience
here so todaya I want to share a little
bit of my perspective on what Asia can
mean for the next generation of silicon
Val
entrepreneurs as um Native Korean
running an of in Silicon Valley for a
Korean
startup so the first half of my slides
are about bingle's Journey from sold to
Silicon Valley but the vingle is the
company I joined last year it's a fast
growing mobile app startup in Korea but
probably none of you guys have heard of
it I think so I'm going to introduce a
little bit about our business and how
should we set up the US
office and the rest half of my slid will
be about my thoughts uh probably just
know just briefly what I like to tell
like a silicon Val people about Asian
startups I'm a little careful when I
mantion like Asia because Asia is such a
big continent where there are so many
different countries are so actually my
experience personal experience this is
limited to Korea mostly though I've been
working on like a lot of different like
Asian markets and other like you know
different countries so when I say Asia
just want to keep that in mind that
actually most of my experience are
actually just limited to
Korea so what is Bingle Bingle is an
interest based Community platform and
Bingle actually created an online
service where users can connect share
and interact with each other who share
the same interest it's offering over
3,000 interest communities from hobbies
for professional topics to fandoms so
should this is the main uh front page of
of our website before you sign up and
actually you can get to actually choose
what interest you have what communities
you're interested in joining and then
after you sign in then actually this is
the first page actually you get to see
because actually I selected like a pet
community and funny stuff and food those
contents actually show up to me first
but if you just know selected like movie
or soccer or any other like a hobby
you're interested in actually only those
content will show up to you when you
sign up and sign in so I'm not going to
go through too much about our product I
know sure there is a time limit for my
presentation so I'm going to just try to
go fast so vingle was first launched in
Korea 5 years ago and it actually grew
up very fast and become very successful
in Korea hitting 10 million monthly
users last year and it's now it's a top
ranked interest based social networking
service and app more popular than
Twitter Instagram or Pinterest in Korea
and some of the largest communities on
Bingo have over like millions of members
each only in Korean so our business
model is mainly advertisement it's
working pretty well so far because I
think all the users already uh said
actually they interest they are strongly
interested in this this this topic so
there's you know on social media there's
a little resistant to you know
advertisement people just don't like
just nwing too many advertisements on
social media but I think there's less
resistance and vingle because they
really don't mind like seeing a little
more like advertisement content so it's
going really well and we decided to set
up the US office in Paulo Alto late last
year and actually we uh we are just
doing like a marketing activities and
community building activities for the US
market since
then actually Bingle actually set up a
pretty uh firm and clear Global business
strategies from the beginning so uh one
uh really goodl one good policy for us
is like one product Vision where should
we want to build just one Global product
just keeping the product same product
pictures across the markets providing
the service in just many different
languages and to just make this possible
uh the company just like a built very
like a international team like a
multinational team like a from the
beginning of product concept and
development stage and we hire like most
of the employees like a Korean English
bilingual people it might not sound very
you know great here but it's very rare
in Korea and I believe it's probably
rare in Asian companies so the the
company really tried hard to make the
team and the company and product very
like a international or like a a global
like from the beginning of the the the
business instead actually we tried hard
to make marketing localized which means
actually we want to support users in
different markets in the best way that
suits that specific market so should we
have uh Regional Offices in US Japan and
also southeast Asia so that we can
develop marketing strategies peer
strategies and also do more like a
Content uh content strategy for those
markets specifically by working with a
product team in Korea together even
though should Bingo like a started like
a pretty like a with a global vision for
the product not like other like a Korean
companies who mostly just focus on
domestic Market first and then expand
globally
later there are a lot of other lot of
challenges which we are facing here in
the states so I'm not going to go
through like a too much about everything
but one thing is like a user behavior is
definitely different which requires
actually just different product features
for us so there are a lot of discussions
about that internally and this is a live
service so this is an online service
actually the product product should be
in evolving so there are a lot of things
actually we have to do with our product
team in Korean but the live service the
product stage is different in different
markets for example you're still like in
a very early stage in this in the in the
US market but in Korea we already grew a
lot and there are a lot of users Rec
created like a we started creating some
Revenue so actually there are different
issues on the product side actually what
we have to do to support those users and
what we have to do to make more money in
different markets but unfortunately the
priority is in the Korean market so
there are a lot of challenges that are
caused by that so of course you know
there are a lot of Co cooperations and
Communications going on between the
product team in Korea and marketing
teams in different regions but it's not
very easy to coordinate everything and
make everything happen and I think
actually this is more problem for us but
there are different competitors in
different Market especially here you
know we are competing with like a lot of
bigger like a social media companies and
even like you know like a Reddit you
know they don't exist in Korea people
just don't know about like Reddit or
BuzzFeed but we realize that they have
to come up with how I sh know the ideas
how we can differentiate from those
competitors here it's not just about
different competitors too competitors
are playing in a lot bigger scale the
funding size is different their
marketing budget is different the
resource actually they can pool is
totally different from us so there are a
lot of things that we have to figure out
actually to success to be successful in
the US market there are cultural
differences but this is probably
something all the companies are facing
when they go you know outside of their
domestic market so I'm I'm not going to
talk about it here so this is just
briefly about actually what Bingle is
actually what we are doing here in
Silicon Valley and whyu came afteru
pretty like a successful in Korean and
from my experience from Bingle and from
like other companies I worked for here's
a little bit about what I'd like to tell
like Silicon Valley people about Asian
startups again actually there are so
many different aspects I can talk about
for Asia or Asian startups but yeah
because of the time limit I'm just going
to talk about one thing and go from
there and when I say Asia it's mostly
about Korea but I think actually can
apply for other startups from many other
as I countries so this is a very simple
fact silicon Val is not the only place
where great ideas are born it's very
obvious but here I think a lot of people
doesn't forget that often
so uh actually just know in the back in
1990s and early 2000 even some of the
Korean startups like I started with
exactly the same business ideas as
Facebook or YouTube and many other
services that are popular here in
Silicon Valley now you might have heard
of these companies like Sor they had the
very very similar concept with Facebook
but now actually they are almost gone
even in Korea they were very popular in
like early 2000 and pendora TV is very
similar to YouTube they also started
their business a lot earlier than uh uh
YouTube became popular here and Africa
TV they have very similar model with
twitch here so all the services and many
more actually came first in Korea and
other Asian markets but they even like
it got they didn't you know have a
chance to be discovered here or used by
the users outside of Korea unfortunately
even now a lot of interesting ideas and
services keep coming out and
growing but I think as most of this like
a Korean startups just like I want to
stay in the domestic markets only for
many different reasons but this this is
like a kick survey by uh uh done by like
IBM uh research group I think at last
year and they asked like the startups
whether they are expanding their
business outside of Korea and only 9% of
them said yes we are and majority of
them were not even actually when they
said actually yes we are planning it's
just know in the planning stage most of
them were not even thinking about
it there are many different reasons but
I think it's still like a language still
like a creates like it puts some limits
on actually what they can do what they
want to do because most of the products
and services like coming out of Asia
they are developed by their local
language first like a Korean companies
as develop their service and products in
Korean language first so this is why
Bingle wanted to go differently from
even from the beginning we actually
developed all the services in English
and Korean together and then just
translate it to other languages all
together even when there was Zero use
user in that
language and also domestic Market in
Asia seems big enough to focus on when
especially when actually we considerer
like their you know internet penetration
like a mobile penetration they really
think actually know it's kind of enough
to focus on which might be true but you
know they usually just don't want to see
know things like over that um market and
there is still like a belief that they
should work on the domestic Market first
to prove themselves before expanding to
any other market and there are also
concerns that they will lose the
competitive advantage in other countries
which are all true but even when there
are good reasons to go overseas and even
when they are very ready it's really
hard for Asian startups to you know come
to sel Aon valy or to do anything in the
States because actually they are mostly
like a funds and resource to support
that lack of funds and resources you
said yeah okay yeah MH so this is a
chart I found uh made by met Mark uh
this year this is the average of funding
size by country so uh actually the in
the original chart there was no Korea so
I just use my own data and then just
like put the Korea the the uh at last so
compared to other countries I think I
should probably this is similar to other
Asian countries but actually the funding
size is still very very small so even
when they're like ready to do more it's
really hard for them to do a lot of
things at the same time with this like a
little funding and actually when they
are not really at a a revenue stage so I
think actually this is actually one of
the biggest reasons actually why a lot
of the startups in Asia just want to
stay in there not really just do trying
to just go more Bal
ambitious yeah so recently actually
there is a trend actually Korean
startups actually get funded by big S
caneles actually this data is a little
outdated but the first one coupon
actually they got a lot more fundings uh
recently they got 1 billion uh by S Bank
Ventures and also the the last one and
the second row like a Brothers they also
get funded by Goldman Sachs last year so
these companies are growing very fast
and very well like doing really well in
Korean but still I think it should there
is to be more attention and for more
investment uh by silicon valy Ventures
for for Asian
startups so I just like to put some
implications for Silicon Valley just to
know wrap up my short talk I think Asia
or Korea is not just a great market for
silicon value uh companies I think I a
lot of them just we're looking at them
just more for potential Market where
they can sell their product but actually
like a it's also a birthplace of great
ideas and resource for Creative Minds
good great engineers and passionate
business people as I said people just
know forget that pretty often so when
you think about that I believe there's a
lot of room for cooperation and
partnership opportunities between
Silicon Valley companies and Asian or
Korean companies Korean
startups and because of this I think I
should both Asian and silon Val startups
can learn from each other by working
together and just to make this happen of
course actually Asian startups need
actually more or Fair attention from
Silicon Valley investors companies and
entrepreneurs they just know need more
like media coverage more investment and
more Partnerships so that they can also
just like spread their ideas and just
grow their business in Silicon
Valley okay thank you very much F while
I'm setting up the next set of slides
I've got a follow-up question for you
the one thing you didn't say is why did
uh vingle decide to not only come to the
US but to set up shop in Silicon
Valley actually we were not really just
thinking of a Silicon Valley itself we
were just looking at different cities in
the US just
to start with for the US market and then
definitely I think it should this very
just common conversation just know going
around like among the Korean startups if
they really want to do something in the
state they want to be in the best spot
best place just to do that so when you
think about I think you should Silicon
Valley of course it's a great you know
uh place for great ideas great startup
ideas but I think it's a really great
place for the startup ecosystem and
there are just so many in a great
networks that we can take uh can take
care of so the company even you know
despite of the the expense and all the
you know cost that we have to bear does
the company just wanted to just be in
here just to just you know have more
like Leverage did they look previously
at all at the companies like Sor that
sort of didn't get involved in the
valley and so now they're not doing so
well do you think that was part of it is
that one reason they went bilingual
English Korean from the very beginning
yeah I think all of that are probably
relevant because actually most of the
Korean Services as I said actually they
are just developed in Korean language
and then all the like a cultural you
know differences they really like it can
be mitigated when they just like just
translate the service into another
language but when they just do this like
a kind of localization process after she
they already got really famous or really
big in one market then I think it's it
gets pretty hard for them to make
everything right for other markets so
definitely I think it's that's one of
the reasons yeah okay and one last
question for you before we go on this is
not an I would call this space kind of
crowded right you mentioned the
companies around here that are are doing
similar
things
um that's kind of you know it must have
been hard to get people to take you
seriously here
M what was the best what was the thing
that most accounts for you being able to
be taken
seriously no usually just know I just
talk about how popular we are in Korea
how well actually we're doing in Korea
but even when I say that I don't think
actually I my company should get kind of
a fair attention from Media or other
companies that we love to know make a
partnership with probably because we
don't have like a strong presence here
so this is actually one thing I'd like
to ask you know those companies too like
you know there are like so many great
like a startups outside of Silicon
Valley outside of the us but they they
just think um they're not I've never
heard of them my friends never heard of
them so probably they're not really like
a significant business but they are and
they have great potential and one thing
is really you know one thing I always
just want to talk to uh talk about to
like those like a potential Partners to
us is if you guys like grab us like at
an early stage you guys can get a really
good deal like at a like a great price I
mean you know once I should these
companies get really big then you know
it's it's going to be hard for them to
negotiate with you know companies like
us but if you guys I think it's kind of
like a similar you know when actually
when you know you move to a new
neighborhood you need a new friends but
those friends like don't know about you
oh and they're like oh actually he's
from like a Countryside he never you
know gets they they never know gets to
see your real you know strengths and
then once actually they get to see those
he's already like one of the most
popular people in your class so it's not
going to be easy for you to make friends
with him anymore so when they're not
really discovered by other people you
can take advantage of that opportunity
just you know by you know approaching
you know first and then just know
grabbing that thank you you have
just said very eloquently one of the
main points I wanted to get across today
great ideas coming across from Asia that
we should not ignore if you had passed
the Baton over to David David would you
tell us about yourself and about module
Q sure well Richard thank you for
inviting me to join you today uh good
afternoon am I is the audio okay thumbs
up okay uh so um I'm a uh academic
turned entrepreneur uh with a background
in artificial intelligence and my
passion is trying to figure out you know
AI has been in the news a lot recently
mostly in the context of is AI going to
take your job or take over the world but
is AI G to take your job and I my
Fascination has been with how do we get
AI to actually enhance your job and I
think for for some folks unfortunately
truck drivers and taxi drivers being
notably notable examples the the
handwriting is kind of on the wall we're
probably not going to enhance those jobs
um but for most of the jobs that we
think about in the knowledge economy and
certainly if your job requires empathy
uh or if it requires creative problem
solving you have a really good chance
that AI is going to make you more
valuable rather than less valuable and
that's a something that I've always
wanted to be a part of so I started out
uh doing my undergraduate work here in
computer science uh I worked with Edward
Fen Bal who invented expert systems and
did a lot of pioneering work in AI uh
did some work with him on uh data Fusion
systems to detect cyber warfare attacks
um and now I'm I'm starting to take some
of those ideas and apply them in my
current company so um Richard already
gave a far better introduction for me
than I can um but but I did leave out
one thing you co-authored a book with uh
Professor Fen Bal about entrepreneurship
in Japan so I did write a book that is
now unfortunately uh severely out of
date it was published back in 2002 about
entrepreneurship in Japan uh a lot has
changed uh with Japanese
entrepreneurship since then uh notably
the m&a and IPO markets have have
developed a lot um and and there seems
to be a more V vibrant entrepreneurial
scene there um but the only thing I'd
add to the introduction is that I've
I've done a lot of sort of going back
forth between the US and Japan and so in
the same way that JJ commented that her
perspective is sort of uh tilted toward
Korea my perspective is tilted toward
Japan uh to be quite honest I really
don't know much about the rest of Asia
um but I'm happy to talk about you know
Japan is a is a pretty good-sized
constituent in Asia and so I'm happy to
talk about that uh so my current company
module Q um is building on ideas that I
first encountered here at Stanford in a
book called in the age of the smart
machine and this was written by HBS
Professor uh shishana zubba all the way
back in the 80s um and she made a point
that I thought was really important uh
and the book actually reads pretty it
feels pretty current now because she
went into a lot of work settings and she
found that in many cases unlike the
examples of the taxi drivers or the
truck drivers managers actually have a
choice about whether to use intelligent
technology to replace workers and
automate their jobs and deskill them or
to use it to empower them and help them
do their jobs and make better judgments
and the um the distinction she
characterized as automate versus
informate uh informate is kind of a
mouthful I prefer the the term augment
um but when I read that it seemed to me
that uh the world was going to need
people who were committed to Building
Technology that would augment humans um
because that's the kind of world that I
at least want to live in so that's what
I'm doing at module Q uh and we build
technology that we call personal data
Fusion uh which is it's kind of taking
the data Fusion idea turning it on its
head so paler is in the news aot for
data Fusion uh the NSA is in the news
aot for data Fusion taking data from
lots of different sensors putting it all
together to figure out what's going on I
figure that if the NSA can use these
systems to figure out what you're doing
why can't you use them to figure out
what you're doing uh so so we turn the
whole thing upside down and focus it on
your work um we tap into various data
sources email calendar contacts and
others uh workflow systems as well that
you use in your work uh we take privacy
really really seriously we believe that
uh total transparency kills Innovations
so you need personal space you need
privacy that's something we're committed
to uh we have one of the leading uh
researchers on the uh implications of
excessive transparency in organizations
on our board um but our first product
I'll I'll just touch on very briefly we
call it rev uh and it's designed to cut
through information overload uh for B2B
sales professionals and help them be
more responsive to their customers uh so
uh we're we're currently pre-released
for those of you who are already looking
for it on the App Store the version
that's there is an alpha not supported
please give us another 2 weeks to get
the uh the beta version out um and this
is something that you know we're still
in in seed uh seed stage with this um
but we're we're pretty excited about it
so uh with that let me oh um the
importance of responsiveness um for
those of you are into sales I think this
actually applies to all knowledge work
and it's a way that that AI can help us
be more effective is being more
responsive and there's actually some
great research that was done here at
Stanford showing that in big complex
projects it's actually resolving the
interactions between people that ends up
slowing things down and stretching out
timelines and so if you can get
everybody to be really rapid fire being
more responsive you can shorten
timelines and in sales at least you can
increase win rates and so if AI can help
you focus on the most important thing uh
and help you prioritize that's pretty
powerful so let me talk about what what
Asia uh what Japan has meant to me um in
my entrepreneurial Journey uh and I've
actually module Q has involved a lot of
Rd and so we're still seed stage but I'm
actually five years in uh I've been
full-time on it for five years um over
the course of that five years we've
raised um several million dollars in
seed funding uh but U more than one and
a half million came from people that
were connected to Japan and I I want to
bring this up not because it's a lot of
money it's not um you know we saw the
average Chinese series a is like 100
million or something at this point it's
a small amount of money but something
that I think anyone who's been on
entrepreneurial and silicon
entrepreneurial journey in Silicon
Valley recently will probably be pretty
familiar with is that for ideas that
that aren't quite in fashion or that are
a little bit hard to grasp and they sort
of require some exploration and some
pure R&D it's actually pretty hard to
find the risk Capital that will let you
just go out there and experiment and
explore and so for me part of that risk
Capital came from contacts in Japan uh
who uh for whatever reason were not in
the the current uh group think in
Silicon Valley and so I think with all
of Asia it can be really powerful to be
able to reach out uh for some of that
early stage risk capital for example
some of it also came from Silicon Valley
as sources as well U but it was powerful
to have the Japan angle uh so so flow of
capital um I also want to talk about
flow of ideas uh although JJ already
already touched on that but uh a lot of
the ideas and when I talk about that uh
the power of responsiveness for example
the power of shortening the interaction
Cycles um that's also known as Just in
Time Manufacturing and there's a car
company in Japan that did a pretty
impressive job of of sort of figuring
that all out with the Toyota production
system and so um the way that I came to
those ideas and the idea of applying
Toyota production system ideas to
knowledge work uh was actually through
the research of a colleague of mine at
shinai Bank in Japan and it was my Japan
Network that led him to say oh gee when
you're over in Tokyo you should meet
these people you should hear what
they're working on and I went there and
it turned out that what they were doing
was exactly the kind of ideas that I
wanted to begin to bring use AI to bring
to knowledge work um and so those ideas
um ended up becoming a platform in many
ways for my
company um and the the third sort of uh
leg of the pyramid is people and there
are lots of people for me in Japan that
have influenced my business and my
entrepreneurial uh experience but I want
to to highlight a coule of them and also
to highlight that they're not all
Japanese they're all people that have a
Japan Nexus uh one of them is a native
Japanese who won the US Japan Innovation
award a few years back mitsuru mitsuru
isimo the the CEO of ugena which is I I
knew actually since he was a participant
in the first uh Asia Pacific student
entrepreneurship Summit that I organized
here at staford that was how I got to
know him uh and his company is now um uh
public and traded on the first section
of the Tokyo Stock Exchange and he's
been an INSP Iration and actually
someone I've looked to repeatedly
because U one of the things that I
really respect about Japanese
culture is that there's often a
willingness to persevere even when the
odds seem impossible uh and even when
most people would have moved on to the
next hot new thing if you believe in it
to really just keep on tweaking it and
tuning it and I watched eano succeed in
an impossible environment Against All
Odds bringing his uh algae technology to
Market um and it was it was an
inspiration to me that whatever I had a
dark day I would think of him and I'd
know that when he had a dark day like I
was having he never would have given up
um and uh the other two gentlemen here
I'll mention just in passing but jetti
is the uh indian-born uh former CIO of
shinai Bank who developed some really
radical ways to uh engineer Enterprise
systems and probably the only way that
he was ever able to put them into
practice and try them out and experiment
and then pass on what he learned to me
uh was the fact that a Japanese Bank Shi
Bank ended up being bought by a
Consortium of investors including
ripplewood when bizarrely the Japanese
government decided to send it sell it
off to foreigners and so that created
again a cross pooll cross polonization
an opportunity uh for new ideas to
emerge and Alan Miner as some of you
here will know is uh is our chairman and
Lead investor uh the founder of Oracle
Japan founder of salesforce.com Japan so
it's sort of an interesting twist that
he was bringing us technology to Japan
now he brings Japan back to Silicon
Valley um I'll close just with with a
definition of Entrepreneurship that I
like because I think this is at some
level about Asian and Entrepreneurship
and I think it's uh it's one way to
think about entrepreneurship is just
sort of the building company Silicon
Valley style but another is is Professor
Stevenson's definition from HBS of
Entrepreneurship is the pursuit of
opportunity Beyond resources controlled
and those resources may be technology
and ideas or capital or people and my
observation has been that the broader
you cast the net sort of the strength of
weak ties in your network the broader
you cast the net the more likely you are
to find that resource that you need and
to be able to access it when you need it
uh to realize your entrepreneurial
Vision so I think on that level
connecting with Asia and connecting
around the world is really powerful
thank you David while I'm setting up the
next next slides so people old sign and
maybe even to a certain extent Allen
they invested in your company here and
I'm kind of curious if they took heat
from people in Japan saying that we
don't have enough you know Venture
Capital money we don't have enough
investment money in Japan and so you
should keep your money at
home if they did they didn't tell me
about it isimo is has set up his own uh
Venture Capital fund as a branch in
although they're focused it's kind of a
a unique Japanese angle on things
because they say we only do stuff that's
not pure software it's got to have a a
physical mon component to it um but my
perception is actually that early stage
Venture cap or early stage capital in
Japan uh as far as I can tell and
they'll probably be experts even in the
room who may know better than I do uh
but is not now that hard to come by uh
expansion stage capital I think a little
bit more challenging but at this stage
I'm not competing for that yeah okay no
and I think that it's just fine feel
free to talk about ideas and people as
well as to talk about money right so but
if I could ask you to give your comments
sure uh so by the way I'm just
recovering over sore throat so just
forgive me for this um but I'm going to
do something a little bit different uh
my question or my topic is really the
question of Asian leadership in siling
Valley and let me start the discussion
with this story so I was acquired by
Cisco in 2004 I think U Richard said
that in 2006 I was sitting at my desk
reading my email uh one Sunday morning
when I
realized I'm the only Chinese vice
president engineering
here and and I said I wonder if that's
true so I sent an email to Charlie Jin
Carlo at the time was head of
development
Cisco and I said Charlie I i' just been
here for a couple years maybe there's
some people I don't know right um there
you know 20,000 engineers in the US am I
the only one and Charlie wrote back and
said you know Buck you are the only one
uh I've of often noticed that myself and
and wondered why you know can you find
out what's going on what can be done
about
it so those questions from Charlie led
me to the things I'm going to talk about
today okay uh as some background I think
you heard some of this I started out as
a computer designer uh adhp actually my
fellow computer designer back from 1972
is sitting over in the corner
Kenyon uh he's smarter than me he got a
PhD so obviously he was better uh uh I I
got tired of that so I went back to
business school okay uh I worked at big
companies and small I started with HP I
ended up with Cisco in between I started
or was part of six startup teams uh
three good ones three nuts of good ones
you know so I I made some VC's money and
lost a lot of money for other VCS okay
that
happens um uh uh so I was acquired by
Cisco in 1993 that was like Cisco's
first acquisition
Crescendo uh com2 was a m m company went
public and then my last company was
acquired by Cisco in 2004 where I became
general manager and vice
president uh a lot has changed since uh
since uh I I graduated from Stanford
actually I I used to have my um
undergraduate circuit design class in
this
room and there were about 30 people okay
there is there was one woman
woman and three Chinese guys okay that's
it you know in s in 1970 there are 1.5
million Asians in the
US now there's 1.5 million in the Bay
Area so a lot has changed okay um and
The Narrative of Silicon
Valley is that we're doing great if you
look at uh oh the picture didn't jump
you look at asian-americans 6% of the
population but actually in the valley
we're actually over half of the
high-tech Workforce half of the
professionals are we missing a graph no
no no no not yet not yet okay okay uh it
will be there in a second okay and and
actually the the the a study came out a
couple years ago that either 70
somewhere between 70 and 80% of the
Asians in in the Bay area are either
first or second generation that is
either immigrant or children of
immigrants okay like she's first she
came here right you born in Korea my
father came here so I'm second um so
that is the general narrative and the
question that's generally asked about
asian-americans is this question this
was a a uh oped by Nicholas Kristoff
about six months ago I think six months
ago in the in the New York Times and his
question
is why are asian-americans so successful
successful you know because we're too
successful is
implication all right well that's not my
view when I'm the only one so let's look
at the data about us or Asian-American
Silicon Valley and this is a a a very
complicated chart but I'll work you
through it this is EEOC data and there
are every company greater than a 100
people must file an E1 report and E1
report is an interesting report it has
uh each race and gender by job
category so you can look at each race
and gender as professionals individual
contributors managers and
Executives and so if you look at the
chart on the left it looks at the men
and you look at the chart on the right
it's women okay and within each chart is
by
race so the general Narrative of men is
they're doing great if you look at the
Top Line it's that red line they're
doing great they're 71% of professionals
and
what 81% of
Executives but then when you break it
down by race you get a different story
by race if you look at the white men
they doing great it's a it's a it's a
it's a linear all right it's a line
between 31% to
50% look at Asian men they start at 30
6% so actually more Asian men in the
workplace than white men but but it
doesn't go up it goes
down 36% to 27% the other curves are are
in in the 2% rate those are blacks and
Hispanics so it's clear what the their
problem is their problem is there there
are not enough of them in Silicon Valley
the Asian problem is there's lots of us
okay but we're not doing well to the
pipeline okay on the right
is the curve for women if you look at
the blue curve on the top it it it sells
a general Narrative of of women that is
to say it's 26% of pro professionals and
then it drops down to 7 12% 177% 17% of
Executives goes down but another
interesting thing happens when you break
down by
race if you look at white women they 9%
of professionals
and almost 11% of
Executives it went
up but the reason and the reason that
the overall number went down is because
if you look at Asian women there are
more Asian women than white women in the
workforce and they're they're if you
look at that curve it's a straight line
down the other numbers are blacks
Hispanics again their issue is their
issue is um uh they're just not enough
that's clear it's hard to compare though
if you just look at these numbers an
easier way to compare it is is that you
take a normalized index you look at what
the pipeline looks like okay independent
of the numbers all right and this is
what the pipeline looks like for for
white and Asian men and
women um so it's everything just a one
white men basically go from 1 to
1.6 what women go from one to
1.19 and the Asian men and Asian women
okay is that clear what this chart
shows so so once you look at the
normalized index then you can compare
you compare each
cohort what this says is that that white
the gap between terms of relative
performance through the pipeline white
men are doing 39% better than white
women that's what it
says whoops
hello that's not
good there we go got it but before while
I got to stop sure about what year is
this survey sorry I should tell you this
is EOC 20
2014 data actually I have the data from
2014 um but I decided not to show it's
you look at
2014 data so the latest one they have
this on the EOC website they actually
want to look at the data they actually
have the data they actually have the
data sets you want to put in spreadsheet
like I did and do the same thing okay
anyway this says white women uh white
men are doing 39% better than white
women okay so it's clear there's a
there's a gender problem okay
um Asian men white men are doing 123%
better than Asian
men
and Dr comparison say and and white men
are doing
340% better than Asian
women there's another there's analysis
you can go through in looking at the
gender versus racial Gap and what you do
is you look at the you look at the
gender gap the difference between white
men and women Asian men and
women and then you look at the
difference between white women and Asian
women white men and
Asian men so you can look at the gender
gap versus the racial Gap and and you
can see that the the racial Gap the
Asian
factor is much much greater than the
gender Factor gender factor is actually
very similar okay for for Asian and
white very similar but the racial gap
for both men a men and women are much
greater than the gender
gap okay that's not interesting and this
this is interesting data not this was
not intended this is not what I was
looking for but it's what I found um and
and surprisingly the actually I've
actually spent some time with EOC and
there's no one else looking at this data
no one else has broken out this data by
by by race and gender so no one's
pointing up this
issue until until we started raising the
question okay it's a question why
right so
um so my argument is so the if you look
at the
data I want to tell a different story
about the Asians in Silicon Valley okay
we're not the success story that that
Nicholas Kristoff says we are okay we're
okay okay but in terms of influence and
power um yeah we're we're most of the
workforce when people talk about Silicon
Valley Innovation when people talk about
Silicon Valley
technology they're talking more more or
less about Asian technology Asian
Innovation cuz that's us
but when they talk about leadership
that's not
us so that's a question
why um as I said if you look at you can
crunch the numbers anything you want the
Asian Factor the Asian glass ceiling
factor is much much greater than the
gender
Factor
okay um lot question about this and and
and for in the sea Suite it's even worse
there's 33% right but I just anecdotally
um you want to know how many Asians are
on the sea suet at
Apple
none or HP the the split-off HP
Enterprise you want to guess
none or
HP none Facebook
none Yahoo there's one a there one Asian
executive in
Asia so
so so so it's even worse at that level
okay this when to say Executives this
this is actually all Asians three levels
the top and three levels so it's the
executive team and then it's like
basically um senior senior VP VPS and
directors okay for as definition all
right
um so what's the
problem my answer that as I said uh
Charlie said can you find out what's
going on and this is what's going on
what can be done about it my conclusion
from a lot of work is it's cultural um
and that by and large Asians need to
understand the the dominant La
management leadership culture in Silicon
Valley um and I'll talk about this in a
minute in ter of his story
um this is a a graph and it was actually
very funny this is I was sitting in a fr
office at
AIG she just started AIG and I said how
AIG says well you know I just took a
long questionnaire that looked at my
management traits the way I manage
people and and they had me and the
question there was by a peran global
appearing Global teaches cultural
sensitivity so for global companies
there can be way the people behave
differently in different
countries so you as a manager you need
to understand the people you need your
team in France is different than people
in in Germany or or Japan or China and
you need to adapt to that style to be
sure you there's no miscommunications on
what you expect and what they're doing
so it really is cultural sensitivity
it's not diversity it's really cultural
sensitivity how to adapt your behavior
so I said that's an interesting question
I I wonder in that case I wonder what
the cultures look like in three Western
countries and three Eastern countries
and I had hoped for something like this
but this was the data that popped out
and it was five different dimensions of
management or
leadership and and and what you what
they would you do is you say where do I
fit and then how do I adapt to that so
what kind of a survey was this so so
this is so what it is is that they they
have a lot of clients and they have um
people taking these questionnaires and
they crunch the numbers and they create
what your curve looks like so this is
the median points for 700,000 people
taking questionnaires so wasn't a survey
it was a questionnaire so this is self
this is your own data this is what you
said you are so you can see in U in US
Canada in UK they're all on one side of
the
cultural curve management curve and
India Japan and China they all put
themselves on the other
side okay um egalitarian versus status
for example you know is basically you
know do you think about Collective or do
you think individualism is a simple
thing uh uh direct versus indirect is
you know are are you willing to to to
deal with conflict or do you just are
you passive aggressive for example and I
was surprised to see that yeah I mean
this suggests that there are cultural
differences in the way that people are
and for most Asian Silicon Valley First
and gen first and second
generation brought up by parents or
growing up in China or Japan you know
you're on that side you have to
understand that most of the valley is on
the other side and you got to understand
what that Gap is and what you need to
adapt to it okay that fundamentally
suggests what the problems are and why
there not as many asian-americans
reaching exective streets because it is
dominantly Western management culture
and if you don't adapt to that then you
are not identified as high potential and
not
developed
um actually I want to go I want to go
uh one slide and then go back to this
one um so as Richard said one of the
things I decided was okay then let in
that case let's let's
teach the you know the high potential
asian-americans um what leadership is in
the valley I went out looking for a
class to do that I couldn't find
anything at that level everything all
the leadership classes you could find
are also mid essentially middle
management
leadership okay middle management
management so I talked Huggy R who's
actually sitting the front right beside
me there who is Professor at the
GSB I said here's the problem da da da I
think we need to teach them these issu
there's some thick issues I want to
address and and I was able to talk into
doing this um because he was actually
thinking about doing a CEO of boot camp
for
Asians and because because he had gotten
word from his Venture Capital friends
that yes a lot of Americans are
entrepreneurs and start companies but
when they get big and become real most
of them get replaced because they don't
know how to be a
CEO and those same factors that that
same factors that I would find in
corporate same issues so he said oh it's
great you know it's a bigger Market
there are more Executives and more
companies than that than than VCS in the
valley so we've been running this
program since 2010 we get about 40 50
people a year all funded by their
companies okay but the point
is that that Huggy made yeah you can
start a company but when it becomes real
you get replaced unless you understand
there's a difference between technical
management and organizational
leadership in summary
um if you want to understand um kind of
What It's Like These are great books uh
sh sh sandberg's book her her lesson for
women or or almost all the all all the
same things I would say Asians have
problems with you know leading and
stepping up arguing uh Power is is a
book by Jeff feffer Jeff is a professor
at the Sanford business school and and
he he is a very controversial um
approach uh about building influence
doing things to build influence in
organizations and you are and you get
things done through through
relationships and through personal
influence right not through technical
knowledge not not for not not not you
know doesn't matter how doesn't matter
you work hard or you're smart that
that's irrelevant because everybody's
good at enough it's all through personal
influence and I read his book and I I I
may disagree with his premise that's
what way you do it but I I looked at all
the things that you
do to do those things and I realized I
was doing all those things not not
because I was trying to build influence
just because it was the right thing to
do for the company and that's just what
the way I was so the argument is if you
read the book and you're not doing some
of those things then then the likelihood
you'll be executive perceived as
executive leader is not as high as it
would be
okay I I was fortunate I was lucky
enough to to kind of fall into that kind
of personality to do those things most
Asians do not that I've seen in in in in
certainly in my organizations in Sil
Valley okay so actually I think that's
an incredibly important point and I
think that this sort of perception of
culture is one of the biggest issues
what you were talking about JJ about you
know people don't take your startup
seriously there's a great deal about how
you present your startup here that kind
of goes against the way you present
things in Asia yeah I mean that's a
really powerful you know cultural median
about whether you're independent and
whether you're status conscious or
egalitarian conscious uh one question
for you and then I'll turn this to the
floor do you see change how much have
you seen change say when when you
started this program for the GSB was
like what five or six years ago 7 or
years
ago the the program on Asian yeah yeah
uh has Valle changed um well not so much
has the valley changed but are we seeing
a change early in progress or do you see
any indications of that I I I think it's
I think it's too early and I'll make
this other make one comment the um one
one question I always get asked is uh is
uh the Millennials are different you're
different right you know Millennials are
different and so we should expect when
the Millennials become uh get into the
pipeline uh it should this should be
radically changeed right uh and I
haven't I haven't seen the data for that
and the reason the reason is this a
couple years ago is again anecdotal this
is totally
anecdotal so there was an article that I
forget what magazine it was in about the
top 150 most influential entrepreneurs
in silic valley right people like
Zuckerberg you know so these are almost
all Millennials a few few older VCS
would throw into this but almost all
Millennials and and about again about
135 of them and I I always when I see
list like that I always do counts and I
counted uh 12% 12% Asian pretty much the
same percentage that when you look at
the top 25 companies in the Bay Area you
look at Asians on the executive staff
it's about 12% so there was no no
difference between established companies
and this list of most influential in
Millennials so you know there's no data
that again I I have no data but at least
at least in terms of perceived
leadership in the valley there's no
change there's some but not many yeah
and I do think that the people are the
key right I mean if people cannot become
leaders here if they can't stay with the
company until the company is the you
know 10 billion a year company then uh
really will we be able to successfully
import the ideas will we be able to have
the kind of flow that really is
essential to the valley continuing to
evolve I think those are a very good
question I agree
um we have a lot on the table not just
the points that buck made but about the
future of Silicon Valley I'd like to
open the floor to
questions
Ed about something does the reverse
brain drain play a role in this at all
um whenever a country um is really
successful at sending students here to
grad school for instance Korea Japan now
China we hear how the local companies
there uh do heavy recruiting here to get
those kids to come back so the sea
turtle effect do you see that playing a
role
um so uh the question question is is the
reverse brain
drain um part of part of what I see and
the answer is no two reasons one if you
actually look at the number of Asians in
Silicon Valley it's increasing okay so
so it's it's it's so there may be some
people going back right but certainly if
you if you look at the numbers in the
valley they're continue to increase
okay I mean so I don't you
know and yeah I don't see it yeah go
ahead so yeah the question is uh that
data incidentally it's it sort of fits
in with a lot of recent economic
research also which is showing out and
difference between first and second
generation I think that will show some
Trends but have you corrected it for
education and uh line of uh discipline
because what may be happening is quote
unquote most of the Asians and I know
that for the Indians there have been
some study tend to be quote unquote
techies
which while a lot more for let's say
more mbas might be going in you know the
proportions may be different and people
who are going to management and C Su
might be people who are Finance or
business if you make that correction
that difference
secondly um my wife 30 years ago did a
difference in implicit theories of
leadership in us and in China yes and it
was dramatically different for for some
of the Norms all the sorts of things
which are masculinity decisiveness Etc
which were here in China at least at
that time were very were not at all
present so the question I have is uh
have you actually tried to dig a little
deeper into those five risk five
attributes so um so the two two two
questions the first the first question
was so last last question do I have have
I dug into deeper in the five attributes
do I know a little bit more than that
second qu the first question was
correction for corre when you do the
statistical analysis to correct for
Education levels and disciplin so so so
the uh so data I have from EOC does not
have that information okay so I can't
use that and and there's some other I
there's some other studies but I'm not
going to comment on those okay um I will
say this your question do people through
finance and marketing if I just look at
the data I know for engineering so we
are all engineering uhuh right is this
pattern still
hor I
will I will tell you this so in Cisco
where 60 60% almost 60% of engineering
is Asian Indian mostly Indian Chinese y
60%
okay when we looked at the high
potential pipeline every year we go
through and it's do an assessment of
hyper this is just
engineers okay it was
15% one quarter of the total population
of of what it ought to
be okay so to answer your question has
nothing with Finance it has nothing to
do it has to do with behaviors and
expectations and some some question but
implicit bias but I do think that um
it's important that your conclusion out
of this is not so much that there's
prejudice against Asians I mean that's
part of the picture but the the point is
that Asians have to do do
something have to develop the leadership
Norms you need to you need to understand
you need to understand leadership norms
and the reason I you need to understand
that is because certainly large
corporations if you're running your own
company that's fine then you get you can
do whatever you want but if you're doing
in a large organization like Cisco or HP
or Intel you're dealing with Norm that
has certain behaviors and expectations
what leaders do you know uh it has to do
with being able to make decisions it has
to do with you know influencing
organization indirect influence
organization it it has to it has to do
with uh I mean willness to pull the
trigger and willness to lead when you
don't know exactly where you're going so
one of the things that I'm curious about
that's a very deep question is will the
leadership style of the valley change as
we have more Asians here as more people
take part in the workforce um there are
people like David who have worked
closely with people like isan and I
think a lot of what you value about him
are some of these traits that you know
may not do so well here in the
valley um but I'm I'm kind of curious if
the valley will change its culture over
time ask
that's to everybody on the
panel and I guess the we were sort of
having some conversations about what
other variables play in here and I think
you've already mentioned that the the
big companies and the entrepreneur
Ventures are very different and I think
even within Silicon Valley you know
Cisco or Oracle are very different
beasts from the companies that are
entrepreneurial now and so the only
observation I have is that I have seen
you know as I'm out looking at other
startups and at VCS um you lots of
different management styles and some of
them kind of bizarre uh and so I think
it's there's a long way from the little
company to Cisco or Accenture with
375,000 people and so my my impression
is that the culture is changing
management culture and the startup space
is changing pretty rapidly and you know
how big the disconnect is because as
soon as they get acquired by Cisco
everybody leaves right so not I guess
Buck you stuck around and made to made
the transition there are a lot there are
a lot of people there are a lot of
people leave um and it does seem like at
the very least having the influx of
people from different backgrounds is
opening up the awareness of the
different kinds of communities you can
have in an early stage venture
what JJ I'd really like to hear your
comments on this I wanted to Ed a little
bit actually when actually the first
question came out because actually uh I
actually came to the states when I was
already 30 so I I to say I struggled a
lot especially when I first like started
school and also first started uh working
after school because actually I think
actually I really like I didn't
understand what works well like in the
um in terms of culture and also I think
actually when we talk about leadership I
definitely think actually Asian people
actually whether they grew up in the
states or whether they just originally
from Asia I think they really need to
learn actually you know what actually
works well actually for you know like a
leadership or management because this
being humble is the best thing you have
to have like as like the right manner
when you deal with other people like in
Asia so even as she went I at school I
always said I oh I'm not doing I'm I'm
not good at this I'm not good at this I
always thought that so sure in my
leadership class I was pointed out by my
instructor all the times she told me
like you say that too much don't say
sorry too much don't say you are not
good at this you know you don't you
don't even need to talk about it so even
when I work I always think you know what
I'm missing because I'm I don't think
I'm really like in the mainstream I
think it's a lot of Asian people even
when they just like they were born and
raised in the US I think they sort of
have this a little bit even actually
when they're a little different from me
I actually feel this a lot and they
because of this doing get that ambitious
just you know just like a you know doing
better at work I think you should
thereare more content about their
current status like oh just know getting
like having a job you know is fine with
me I really don't want to want to don't
want to get to to the CEO level that's
not my dream even I sometimes say that
so I think actually it's very different
when they are back in Asia probably they
can be a little more ambitious because
of all the context and environment that
is totally different for them but when
they're here I think a lot of Asian
people think actually they really just
don't want to get to the top level or
when they don't need to be that
ambitious I think that kind of mind us
is is here a little bit so in terms of
that I think I should probably like
something like a leadership program can
help a little bit but also because I
think Silicon Valley is constantly like
emphasizing like diversity and actually
how beneficial those Like A diversity
can be for like organization and
companies I think culture can change
definitely change but for me it's going
to take a lot of time I think the
corporate culture or any type of culture
has a long history so I don't think it
can really like a change over like you
know 10 years like a 20 years but I
think and hope it's going to change yeah
okay that's a really really good comment
I saw a question back here go
ahead the context of what said in terms
of uh large corporations overseas in
particular in Asia being predominantly
filled by you know Caucasians I was just
wondering in the emper case in this
conversation what is it like for native
Asian you know of that agian country
learns leadership styles here in Silicon
Valley but goes back to say
hypothetically like you know Japan or
for Korea fills an executive position
there and exudes you know those type of
more you know Silicon Valley or Western
you know behaviors in that situation how
is that perceived you know by locals and
to what degree is that can that be is
would that be permissible so this is the
kind of sea tural phenomenon somebody
does pretty well over here and then goes
back to Asia and becomes a CEO of a
major group back there how is that
perceived
question well like even like for like H
like working at an HP Branch like you
know in in in Korea so i' say you know
just hypothetically JJ you know climbed
Franks at HP and she went she went back
to you know Korea but within within the
cultural organization you're saying like
you know HP runs more on the Cheryl
Samberg and the sper power type type of
mentality to what I think let me comment
on this real briefly this is kind of a
little bit okay but it's a little bit
away from what we're getting at the
future of Silicon Valley right but I
think that there is a real difficulty
anytime you gain International
experience how do you sell that
International experience back at home no
matter whether you're coming from here
to the Asia or whether you're coming
from Asia to the US and I was in a a
program sponsored by the National
Science Foundation about rores to China
and what was happening in the labor
market in China with people who are
attorneys
some of them are regarded as of the
attorneys were regarded as very arrogant
requiring much too good conditions sort
of like you would get here in the states
and so they did not do well right other
people were showing you know the kind of
leadership that people have here and and
their organizations were able to accept
them better so I think that the real
danger is for an individual is how do
you Market yourself and what you have
but you had a comment on that real quick
yeah yeah my my my comment actually goes
back to the slide on cultural
sensitivity that appear in global head
you know again what it shows is that the
people you know filling questionnaires
are self-identified as having cultural
traits so if if you if you're on one
side if you're in a just like said if
you're an Asian you grw up in Asia you
come over here you have to understand
what the Western culture is otherwise
you don't fit same thing if you're if
you're on the on the right side you and
and you take your us Style to Asia
you're not going to fit okay so so you
have to be culturally aware of the
dominant culture around you at Cisco we
had we at Cisco in Japan and CIS we had
a Cisco office in
China uh the culture was mostly local
there was Cisco elements to it but it
was still mostly local unless you
understood that yeah then you would you
were not going to do a good job
sometimes the most domestic corporations
are the overseas branches of American
ones um uh I have to uh pretty much call
into things I'd like to make a comment
as we have this cultural change in the
very very early stages kind of going
back to what you said JJ you should
always be looking for competitive
advantage and if you find good ideas
from somewhere that don't fit into sort
of the Silicon Valley soup dour or
whatever everything seems to be really
popular in one particular business line
now you may be able to um achieve some
things that uh would be exceptional
successes the same thing about looking
for people who can support your company
with the funds right the investors to
look for the people that you really need
on your team because of what they know
and what they bring no matter where
they're
from we have been doing this series on
Asian entrepreneurship for more than 15
years and one of the reasons is because
the valley needs to watch Asia we need
to see what this means to all of us and
how we are going to need to change
things to move things further along in
the future uh I want to thank everybody
who has been participating in our
seminars really appreciate you coming
out and supporting what we're doing if
you would please join me in thanking our
uh panel for a great
[Applause]